you know what I'm really hearing you
talk about here is the idea of stakes
right the idea of your readers have to
believe that the stakes are really high
like somebody really might get murdered
and I read this interview with you where
you talk about reading Lord of the Rings
and of course people frequently compared
you to talking and feeling betrayed that
okay if you haven't had read Lord of the
Rings you've had many decades so this is
your spoiler alert okay that after they
throw the ring into the fires of Mordor
and it's destroyed right that they come
back to the Shire and the Shire is like
getting sacked right this the scouring
of the shire and you talked about
feeling betrayed that that the story
didn't have a happy ending but now
you've gone on where basically all
you're right you you know you've become
famous for writing iterations of the
scouring of the shire right and so it
seems like part of what you're you're
taking up for is the idea of keeping the
stakes high yes I do believe that I and
I mean I read Lord of rings when it was
first published in the United States and
actually the illegal pirated editions
today's books issued but they were they
were amazing books and and I couldn't
get enough of them but I was only like
13 years old or something like that so
when I hit when the ring went into the
volcano I had water all these was the
end of story now what why is for so much
more and then I hit the scouring at a
shire and I realized that it wasn't the
unequivocal happy ending yay who the
heroes of one that I thought it would be
and I really didn't understand it it's a
thirteen year old but of course I reread
Lord of the Rings every few years and
I've come to not only understand it but
I have a deep appreciation of it and
Peter Jackson's movies are brilliant I
think they're as good adaptation of um
Lord of the Rings that you could
possibly yet but I do miss the scouring
of Shire which he doesn't include it was
it's an important part of the the book
and it says something important and I
took that too to heart the other thing
about reading Cokie and of course is and
and like Wonder Man it had a similar
effect as in fellowship when Gandalf
dies
what the hell and over died you can't
kill Gandalf he's he's he's the head guy
he knows everything that's going on he's
how would it you know it the other
characters see my kids compared to
handle the four hobbits and his family
and I don't trust Boromir and and
they're gonna get it through somehow
now Toki and later brought him back
witches said you know we're on him back
as like Gandalf 2.0 I know I didn't like
it otherwise I preferred Gandalf the
Grey I've always preferred a great
characters to white characters but uh
you know it if professor Tolkien was
here we could argue about with a candle
sure to come back in but it it had an
enormous effect on me killing again over
killing Gandalf also sets up in the
second book when he kills Frodo oh my
god he killed Frodo Frodo was supposed
to be the hero who's the ring bearer now
Sam is there Ingrid how's this gonna
work out and that was a little bit of a
feint to but all of these things had an
enormous effect on the young me and they
did raise the stakes
the minute you kill Gandalf anybody can
die then you're looking at the members
of the Fellowship is saying who they're
gonna kill next
you know we got we got several extra
hobbits they could be merry and pippin
began to get a little indistinguishable
after a while you know he didn't kill
him he didn't but I was afraid he would
so that's the whole point is to have the
reader on on the edge of a sheet as a
receipt and to not know what's gonna
happen and that's something that I try
to do in my books you know there's a
especially is in the scary parts or the
battles if you're really going into a
battle you would be afraid beforehand
you would have but you know this deep
visceral fear are you gonna survive the
battle I mean nobody knows and I want to
I want that experience for the reader I
want to read her to not just read the
book but to live the book and to almost
be afraid to turn the next page when
suddenly the hero is surrounded by six
big guys
taxes you shouldn't feel oh it's Conan
he's gonna get out of it six guys what
axes nothing you should be terrified
that these six guys would access they're
gonna hack it apart and I guarantee you
if any of you leave this wonderful all
tonight and are confronted with six guys
with axes you'll be scared and we'll
read about you in the Tribune tomorrow
how your hacked-up body was found in
another so so you mentioned the
wild-card series which you've been
editing for basically as long as I have
been alive and it's it's a really cool
concept not only for the reasons you
mentioned about really engaging with
what are the real stakes of superpowers
but also because it's a shared universe
and you've you've collaborated on these
edited stories written by over 50
authors working collaboratively and
you've also edited multiple anthologies
now my personal opinion which you may
agree or disagree with is that a good
editor is actually a much rarer thing
than a good writer so I was wondering if
you could talk a little bit about your
identity as an editor and how it may
differ from your identity as a writer
well I don't know if it's a rarer thing
but you know and some of the anthologies
that I've done anthologies like
dangerous went in warriors rogues I had
a great pleasure of working with Gardner
Dozois who unfortunately one of my
dearest friends in the field he passed
away last year but Gardner was one of
the greatest editors in entire history
of science fiction he won the Hugo Award
for best editor sixteen times which is
pretty amazing and working with him was
on the on those books was incredible I
have edited other things wild cards is a
unique challenge because it is a shared
world I mean when you're editing an
ordinary anthology not that any
anthology is ordinary but when you're
editing a more conventional anthology
you're just buying good stories and they
may have a theme you know it's okay the
theme is unicorns so you invite people
to share brew and they send you a
unicorn story
but all you're looking at is is it a
good story is it a bad story how can it
be improved if it has flaws how do you
fix it with a shared world you still
have that but also all the stories have
to fit together they're all essentially
parts of a whole
they can't have contradictions they
can't have duplications so a lot more
rewriting is required a lot more working
together and a lot more editing so the
wildcards are a very challenging series
to edit but I enjoyed doing that I
actually sort of got into editing almost
by accident the my first published book
was actually a book I edited not a book
I wrote back in at the beginning of my
career in 1973 I was nominated for the
john w campbell award for the best new
writer in science fiction and that was a
brand new award given for the first time
in 1973 Campbell that just died in 1971
and I lost that award it was the first
of many awards that I've lost over the
years in the field but I was nominated
and it is a great honor to be nominated
to voters denominators picked me as one
of the six best new writers that entered
science fiction in the previous two
years at the time there was an anthology
called the Yuga winners and there was an
anthology called the nebula Awards book
but I wasn't nominated for them yet but
there was no anthology for Campbell
Award nominees and I thought they should
be because it would be a guaranteed sale
for me so after I lost that that very
same convention I went to some of the
you know editors why and I said why
don't you have a Campbell Award
anthology just like you have the you go
nebula anthologies and I thought you
know somebody famous would do it and I
could sell them a story it would be
guaranteed sale for me instead they said
oh good idea you do it so suddenly I
found myself editing a book I didn't
know anything about editing books but I
learned on the fly and and I did six
volumes of the series that would be
called the new voices ultimately and
that was my introduction to
to editing entirely by abstinence so you
know watch that if you suggest anything
to someone they may say hey you do it
good idea and suddenly you'll find
yourself working with some people